[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL SAXMAN: Hello, everybody.
And welcome to this week's
episode of Google Maps
Developers Live.
I'm Paul Saxman.
With me this week is--
MANO MARKS: Mano Marks.
PAUL SAXMAN: And today, we're
going to talk about importing,
modifying, and exporting
data from Google Maps.
The idea is that data comes in
a lot of different formats.
What's the easiest way, I think,
to get the data into
Google Maps, modify
that data--
because sometimes data doesn't
look quite right, and there's
some really, really simple
tricks for actually modifying
data within a Google Map-- and
then exporting the data so
that you can re-import
it for later use.
Mano, on the other hand,
is going to talk
about something similar.
But--
MANO MARKS: I'm going to revisit
a demo that I did this
fall, which is parsing a
shapefile, which is a
geographic information
systems format,
directly in the browser.
So we're going to get into a
little bit of HTML5 and talk
about the nitty gritties
of DataView and
byte-by-byte access.
PAUL SAXMAN: Right.
So I'm going to be Mr.
Basic, and you're
going to be Mr. Advanced.
So the approach I took
was actually
just the bare minimum.
So what I wanted to do was to
see if I had a file in kind of
the ideal format, how could I
get that into the Google Map
as quickly and easily as
possible, like I said,
manipulate it if the data
doesn't look quite right, and
then export it out.
And each of these steps takes a
few lines of code, which I'm
going to start off
and show you now.
So what I started with is
this visualization we
did a few weeks ago.
This is the CLIWOC ship data.
I'm not too sure these polylines
are too visible on
your screen right now.
But we have a number
of polylines here
rendered on this map.
So just for a little
more context, a
CLIWOC database, it's--
what is it, 25,000
ship voyages?
MANO MARKS: I don't
remember how many.
I know it's 275,000
data points.
PAUL SAXMAN: Data points.
Yeah, so there's just
a ton of data.
We gave a couple
presentations--
I think that was a
few weeks ago--
on this data set and these
visualizations.
So this is just kind of a
continuation of that.
So it's 250,000-plus points,
25,000 or more voyages.
So it's quite a bit of data.
We're not showing it all on
the screen right now.
I have the slider in
here to actually--
this goes, I think, a range
of about 20 or 30--
no, it's even more than that--
I think about 50 actual
voyages at a time.
So you can see there's
a very rich data set.
There's a lot of data in here.
But as I'm scrolling along, you
can see things like the
polylines actually intersecting
or laying over
the land mass, which is
obviously not something you
expect to see in a
ship database.
So by the way, the
two episodes--
I think they were about three
weeks ago that we did these,
or four weeks ago--
you can go back and see kind
of how we built these
visualizations.
We talk about the techniques
we used and go through the
code for actually
building these.
But this one we showed
previously, as well.
This, actually, is all
the data on one
map at a single time.
And what I did is, actually,
I put mouse event
listeners on here.
So as I mouse over these, I'm
actually changing the opacity
and width of the polyline
dynamically, as we're doing
mouse-over events.
And you can see here, like if I
highlight some of these guys
here, we have some kind of
crazy, messy polylines.
I'm not too sure if this was
actually in the original
processing step that we did to
get the data out of the CLIWOC
database into JSON, which I'm
going to talk about in a
little bit.
But it's just worth using as a
sample case for messy data.
And so you can see this polyline
here that I mouse
over, this orange is England.
This was a ship to, I believe
it was Indonesia.
And there's quite a few points
that are kind of out of
sequence, which, to me,
would mean actually
just bad time stamps.
So what I did for
this week is--
whoops, that's not mine--
is I took the exact same data
set, pretty much the exact
same visualization.
But I'm just doing one
line at a time.
I actually kind of made them a
little bit wider so that we
can a little more easily get
the mouse-over event.
And now the slider actually
just goes
one voyage at a time.
So you can see here, as I slide
from left to right, I'm
just going voyage by voyage.
The little number on the top
left there, which is 1493
right now, that's just the
identifier from the
original data set.
And these are actually ordered
chronologically, I believe.
So what I did, though, with
this visualization--
so this is kind of fun, just
to look at the data.
We found a messy one there.
That actually just looks like
an inverted lat/long.
So what I did with this one is
the mouse event-- what happens
now is, actually, I'm making
the polyline editable.
And this is actually a feature
of the Google Maps API.
So a polyline has a setEditable,
getEditable,
mutator, and accessor
method on it.
And I think it's also
a property in
the polyline options.
So you can make it editable
by default.
But this time, what I did is
just, as I mouse-click, I
switch the polyline
to editable.
Then what I can do is I have
listeners on these markers
here, or these controls,
on the polyline.
So if I click one of these,
actually, what I'm going to do
is delete it.
You see now my data looks
nice and clean.
The other thing that you can
do with these-- and this is
kind of a little more advanced,
and I didn't really
cover this in the code--
so you see here that there's
two shades of markers, or
controls, on these polylines.
The dark ones are actually
ones that are part of the
original data set.
And the light ones
are virtual ones.
So if I grab one of these and
drag it, it will actually
create a new point in
the polyline path.
So the ones that are
fully opaque, I
can drag those around.
And you get a little undo.
And the ones that are slightly
transparent, if I grab one of
those and drag it, it
becomes a real node.
And also, once again, you
get the little undo.
And you can only undo once.
So again, this is all kind of
default functionality or basic
functionality of the Maps API.
I can c you a little bit
of code, how I do this.
So let's get Sublime Text
a little bigger.
And then I'll go back and show
you some of the techniques I
use for loading the data in.
MANO MARKS: Can you bump
the font up a bit?
PAUL SAXMAN: Absolutely.
How's that?
So this is the polylines3,
the last one that I
just showed you here.
So first, I'm going to show
you, actually, the event
handling that I did for
making it editable.
And you'll be amazed at
how simple it is.
So I have a method in here
called create polylines, which
just allows me to do a closure
around attaching events to the
polyline when I create it,
instead of just creating it in
a loop, which makes it a lot
harder to attach events.
So what I'm doing here is I just
have a listener, a click
event listener, on
the polyline.
And so here, I'm
checking if the
event.vertex is not undefined.
So I'm basically saying,
have I clicked on a
vertex on the polyline?
And if not, I'm just going to
make the polyline editable.
So the vertex event only occurs
if you're already in
the editable mode.
If you're not in the editable
mode, I'm just going to make
the polyline editable.
So you click the polyline.
If it's not in editable mode,
it's going to become editable.
Otherwise, if it already is
editable and you click on a
vertex, then I'm going to
execute this code in this
statement here.
And so here, what I'm doing is
I'm just taking the line,
getting the path, and removing
the vertex at that particular
index, because that's actually
taking it out of the path for
the polyline.
And then here, I'm actually
going back to my original data
set and taking that vertex out
of the original data set.
And this was pretty easy.
All I did earlier, when
I loaded the code, is
I assigned an index.
So this is going from a polyline
back to my original
data set index, and so
getting that out.
And I'm deleting the element
from the array.
This is a little bit of a tricky
statement, just because
when you delete an
item out of an
array, it becomes undefined.
But it doesn't matter in our
case, because everything works
out the way we expect.
And I'll explain that
in just a minute.
So another thing that I put in
this visualization here so we
could edit it--
so of course, once you've edited
the data, you want to
get it back out so that you
can actually use it later.
I put this little button
way up at the top.
It's a little bit small.
Let's see if I can zoom in.
There we go.
And click that guy here.
It opens up a new window.
It sits here for a little bit,
because I'm actually doing
document.write for the
entire data set.
And you can see here, we have
the data back out again--
oops, there we go, make it
a little bit bigger.
So you can see this might look
a little bit familiar.
It's actually just
JSON format.
So that's the trick
for actually
importing and exporting.
And I'll show you that now.
So importing the code,
even easier.
So exporting is in JSON.
But importing is actually
a little bit easier.
All I did for importing--
and I said I'm going to do the
very basics here today--
is-- no, I don't want
that guy here--
the whole data set actually
takes quite a long time to
load into Sublime.
So basically, I just formatted
my data kind of in this format
here to load it into my map.
So basically, I just have
the path objects--
in each of those, the ID, which
I mentioned earlier, is
the ID from the original
data set--
the countries, which I
use for coloring, and
then the entire path.
So the path is what
I use for actually
generating the polylines.
So this is actually a JavaScript
script, not a
JavaScript JSON object
or JSON file.
So the benefit of using a script
instead of JSON for
loading files is I can just add
the script tag, and it'll
actually just assign this to
my global context for my
application.
If you're using JSON, what you
have to do is you have to put
the JSON in a file, you have to
do an XHR request to load
the data, and then you actually
have to send the data
to the JSON parser to get
in your visualization.
So the benefit of this is that
you don't need to do all the
extra coding to actually get
the data into your map.
The negative side is this
really isn't portable.
So this data is really specific
to my application.
Other people can actually
load the data.
But the catch is that this
variable may already be
assigned within the global scope
for their application.
So if somebody wants to use this
data, they'd have to say,
well, I have to make sure
that I'm assigning this.
Actually, I think in my data
set, I use data equals.
Data is the variable name, which
is probably the least
generic version--
or the most.
Anyways, it's probably the
worst naming convention I
could use for portability.
But for my visualization, just
for my personal use, it was
pretty straightforward to use.
You can see here, all I'm
doing is just creating a
script tag, loading that file,
and then all that data is
available to my application.
So it's really just getting
the data in JavaScript
notation and loading script.
I do have to go through a little
bit of manipulation,
because those lat/longs in the
original file, I actually have
to convert those to Google
Maps lat/longs.
I could actually put this in
the original source file,
because it is JavaScript.
It'll just run when I actually
load that script tag.
But I like to kind of keep the
data a little easier to read
instead of using these
Google Map lat/longs.
It also makes it a little more
generic, even though,
ultimately, it's not
at all generic.
Anyway, so creating the
polylines by loading those
lat/longs into these
polylines.
And that's pretty much it.
Exporting the data.
Since this actually turns out to
be a couple lines of code,
which is really nice, all
I'm doing is I'm just
JSON.stringify-ing that
original data object.
So I'm loading the data variable
or the array of
objects in.
And I'm doing the manipulation
using the polyline, but then
actually removing the data from
the original data set.
And then, when I want to
export, all I do is
JSON.stringify and write
that to a new window.
So just a couple lines of
code to export, a few
lines of code to import.
And getting a new map is pretty
minimal code, I think.
There's a lot of limitations
with this approach.
Namely, like I said earlier,
with these polylines, you can
actually manipulate them.
So instead of just deleting
nodes, I can actually drag
nodes around.
So this code that I have here
actually doesn't support that,
because all I'm listening
for is click
events on these vertices.
If I did want to support that,
I'd have to do a couple of
different things.
Either, instead of serializing
the original data set, I'd
have to actually serialize
this path to JSON.
And that's a little bit tricky,
because this is a
Google Maps lat/long object.
If I just JSON.stringify that,
it's going to look like a
Google Maps lat/long object,
which is undefined, which is
in a public interface,
actually.
So the other approach is I can
actually just manually
stringify this.
Or what I could do is I could
set up more event listeners,
because I do have mouseup,
mousedown, and mousemove
events for polylines.
I could listen for those.
And then, every time you move
a node, go and update it in
the original data set.
Every time I add a node,
insert one to the
original data set.
It's a little bit more work.
I'd probably, just for fun,
code it both ways, because
we're probably talking about
tens of lines of codes for
both approaches.
So maybe a future show.
And with that, I'm going
to hand off--
Mano has some advanced
techniques to show off.
I was going to originally say
minimalist versus whatever the
opposite of minimalist is.
But it's not really that,
because you're really showing
not all data is JavaScript
format, right?
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: A lot
of data is--
MANO MARKS: Do we have mine
pulled up somewhere?
PAUL SAXMAN: Oops, you're
going to have to
load it, I'm sorry.
MANO MARKS: That's all right.
PAUL SAXMAN: So while Mano's
loading the file--
so what he's done is he
has Esri shapefiles.
I think shapefiles are kind
of a generic format now.
MANO MARKS: Where did
you-- sorry, where--
PAUL SAXMAN: There you go.
MANO MARKS: OK.
PAUL SAXMAN: And so lots of
data, lots of GIS data and
Maps data, is actually
in this file format.
So things like the Natural Earth
data we've seen before
with some of our
visualizations.
MANO MARKS: Right.
So a lot of authoritative data
ends up being in shapefile
format, data that's given out
by government agencies,
particularly.
Resource extraction companies, a
lot of places like using the
shapefile as an interchange
format.
And one reason is because, while
it's owned by Esri as a
company, they have opened
the specification.
And it's actually kind
of interesting.
A shapefile is technically
not just a shapefile.
It's multiple files.
PAUL SAXMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
chase it down.
So that directory.
MANO MARKS: OK, there we go.
So shapefiles are generally
distributed as zip files.
And they'll have a bunch of
different files in there.
There's the SHP file, which
is where it gets its name.
And that describes
the geometry.
There's the DBF file, which
is the database file.
It's in an old Xbase format.
Basically, think dBASE 4.
So we're going back to the
early '90s at this point.
Actually, one of my first data
management jobs was working
with dBASE 4 for DOS
quite a while ago.
And by the way, if you're ever
going to write a DBF parser,
don't make the mistake that I
made, which is looking for the
latest dBASE specification,
because, apparently, dBASE
went up to dBASE 7.
The Xbase parser that most of
the DBF files that you'll find
out there is basically
dBASE 4.
And there was quite a
bit of difference.
So I lost a few hours
trying to track down
bytes in that way.
There's a number of other
files in here.
There's a PRJ file, which
tells you what
the projection is.
We're not going to worry
about that one today.
We're just going to assume,
because I know this particular
file is in WGS84, so it's
standard lat/long.
And then there's
an index file.
There's a number of different
files that can be
associated with this.
For our purposes today, we
just need SHP and DBF.
So this is my standard HTML.
I've actually separated out
entirely my JavaScript code
from the HTML file.
Then I have shploadsample.js,
which does the basic loading
of the map and calling out the
SHP and DBF parser files and
then giving them some callbacks
to what to do with
the data once it gets it.
So let me just take a look at
the sample just so you can
orient here.
I actually downloaded, from the
US Census, census track
data for California.
I think it's a 26-megabyte
download.
So that's zipped together.
That's quite a bit of data being
loaded, and it does take
a little bit to load.
I'm not going to show
you that here.
But you can see here, there are
a whole bunch of different
polygons within the state
of California.
And you see, if I click on a
polygon, I actually get an
info window.
And I get the same data here
along in a side panel.
And if I click here, it just
resets the info window and the
side panel.
PAUL SAXMAN: So this is just
one example of the kind of
data you can get, though, out
of shapefiles, right?
MANO MARKS: Oh, yeah.
Right.
We work with polygon data,
country border data.
There's point data, polygon
data, line data.
There's a whole bunch of
different formats that you can
get your data in.
And you could spend quite a
bit of time delving into
shapefiles.
Shapefiles are probably the
third most common data format
that's available on the web.
The most common by far is KML
files, which there's over a
billion of.
Then there's GeoJSON, which is
in numbers in the millions.
And then there's hundreds of
thousands of shapefiles.
But as I said, they're often
authoritative data.
So let's just take
a quick look.
For the SHP file, I'm using a
file called shp.js done by
Ilmari Heikkinen, who's an
ex-Googler, used to work on
the Chrome team.
And he was just interested
in some geometry.
So he released shp.js and then
modified it to remove the
three.js portion that he used,
because I don't use that for
rendering here.
So just to make it
very simple.
And then I created on my own
this dbf.js, which mirrors
that file but parses
out the DBF file--
the database file.
So just to quickly walk through
how shp.js works, we
have this SHP parser, which
allows you to do loading here,
so shpparser.load.
And it takes a URL to
a file, a callback,
and an error function.
And so the URL is the
file that'll load.
The callback is the function
that it will run once you've
completed loading.
And the error is what happens
if something--
what do you do if it doesn't
actually work out?
So we create a new
XMLHttpRequest, XHR.
And we give it a response
type of array buffer.
Now, this is new in HTML5.
Modern browsers support this.
Older browsers don't.
This is allowing you to parse
data as a binary.
PAUL SAXMAN: Which is always
kind of a little bit of a
misnomer, right, because it's an
XMLHttpRequest when you're
loading binary.
MANO MARKS: Yes.
Yeah, that's something
that is a little odd.
The XMLHttpRequest was something
put in to parse XML
data back when that was how a
lot of data got into browsers.
But it is, as you mentioned--
you can load JSON data in it,
you can load CSV data, you can
load a lot of different
formats in.
PAUL SAXMAN: It's basically the
tool you want to use for
loading data across the HTTP.
MANO MARKS: Right.
Now, of course, you can also
only load from the same
domain, because that's a
security feature built into
XMLHttpRequest and prevents
you from doing something
damaging to a user's browser
by loading in potentially
malicious code from somebody
else's domain.
No surprises to the user,
no bad surprises.
And then we create this variable
d, which is the data,
by running the parse function.
And I'm going to walk you
through a few steps here just
to give you a sense
of how this works.
But you can see here, the
parser.parse takes this array
buffer, creates an object.
It also creates a DataView.
And DataView is, again,
new in HTML5.
It's on modern browsers.
It gives you methods to access
the data within a binary array
buffer and then creates this
IDX, which is a variable,
which is just an index, just to
say this is the byte that
I'm at at this moment.
And then the first thing it does
is it gets a getInt32 on
the DataView, which means it's
parsing, basically, the first
four bytes.
And it's just checking to see
that it's got the correct file
code, because SHP files, those
first four bytes always equal
this value here.
And then it just walks through
all these different bytes,
basically creating attributes
for the object.
Here, we've got word length, and
then byte length, and then
the version number,
the shape type.
And then, each time, it advances
the index by a
certain amount in order to get
the next set of bytes.
So here, you can see it's
getInt32, getFloat64.
It's just walking through to
get these values for you.
And then, at some point here,
after a certain number of
bytes, we actually look
at the record.
So much of this is actually
the header for the file.
So you see it's giving you min
and minY, maxX and maxY.
These are the values that
describe the bounding box,
basically, which you're
operating in.
And then each record you are
parsing through to get, you've
got a record number, you've got
a record length, and then
parsing out the shape, which
just defines the--
well, here, we have a whole
parse shape function--
but basically, parsing out the
x- and y-coordinates, and if
there's any other coordinates,
the different coordinates
there, as well.
So other coordinates would
be things like altitude.
And you can see it gets
quite involved.
One of the things you discover
when you're doing this is it's
really very detail oriented.
You're going in deep on, OK,
at byte number four, I get
this value, and it
means this thing.
It's a very deep parsing
kind of thing.
If you miss one byte, everything
looks really wrong,
and you get confused.
You missed the flag that tells
you that you've ended your
search for a particular field.
But it's worth it when you get
to the end, and you're like,
wow, I just did something
really cool.
I parsed a binary file
in JavaScript.
It's pretty awesome.
So the DBF that I wrote--
and by the way, the
shp.js is on GitHub.
Dbf.js, we're going to release
in Google code at some point.
It's in code review right now.
So hopefully, you'll be seeing
that fairly soon.
But I just follow that same
format when I'm walking
through here.
And I actually parse out a whole
bunch of data that you
probably don't even need.
Like there's an encryption flag
that tells you whether
it's encrypted.
There's an Incomplete
Transaction flag that tells
you whether or not the DBF file
was saved at some point
in an incomplete state.
When you get that in a
production file, you're
probably not worried
about this.
So for the shp.js, once I have
parsed through that, the
callback is this shape load,
which, basically, I create a
polygon for each polygon
in this data set.
So you see in here, I actually
check what is the type of the
shapefile and assign the
different types to the object.
But then I go through and I
pull out basically all the
points and create an
MVC array for each
path within each shape.
Let me go back to
the result here.
You'll see that there are
a bunch of polygons.
And some of these polygons
actually have what are known
as inner polygons,
or inner rings.
That is when you have a polygon
that has a hole in it.
And Maps API supports that.
You can set multiple paths.
And if a path is within a
polygon, that will show up as
a hole in your polygon.
PAUL SAXMAN: I call
those doughnuts.
MANO MARKS: Yes, they're
like doughnuts.
Exactly.
Yeah, so it's pretty much
what I've done.
I'm going to actually take
a look in the JavaScript
console, because I have it
log both of the objects.
And I'm not sure if this
is going to be visible
here, or very well.
But let's open that
up a little bit.
This is the SHP file.
And you can see each record
contains an array of objects
that has a shape in it.
It's quite a-- you have to go
SHP, it's the record, record
0, has a shape, has a content.
And you see it's got a maxX
and a maxY in it--
just pulled that off screen--
which defines the boundaries
of the shape.
But then it's got a whole
bunch of points.
And one of the interesting
things about this is shp.js
has longitude and
then latitude.
So that's the point order.
So you have to be aware of that
when you're creating your
lat/long objects.
You have to flip them around.
PAUL SAXMAN: So it's long/lat in
a shapefile, but lat/long--
MANO MARKS: Exactly.
Much like KML files are
actually the same way.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's a
very practical tip.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
So then, in the DBF, we have
the same sort of thing.
We have the number of fields,
which we parsed out from the
file, and then what those
actual fields are.
So here, you can
see the values.
And they're parallel arrays.
So the records in the DBF file
match the records in the SHP
file at the same index.
So the first record is the same
as the first record, the
second record is the
same as the second.
PAUL SAXMAN: So how hard would
it be to export this
JavaScript version of your
shapefile into, let's say, a
JSON file or JavaScript?
MANO MARKS: Very easy.
You see right here, once you
have the code, which Ilmari
and I have written,
these are objects.
These are JSON objects.
So you'd just stringify
that and port it out.
Then you could just
use that without
parsing the object again.
PAUL SAXMAN: Right.
Cool.
When I saw this the
first time, I was
kind of amazed that--
this is a massive number
of polygons, right?
MANO MARKS: It is, yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: I mean, we're
seeing some pretty amazing
performance--
polygon and polyline
on the Google Maps API.
MANO MARKS: Thousands of
polygons, each of which has
multiple vertices.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
The ship data, again,
that's, like,
250-some thousand points.
I'd assume this is actually
beyond that, even.
MANO MARKS: This is all rendered
in canvas on top of
the Maps API.
So you're seeing quite a bit
of performance here.
I mean, you can see how
the different--
these are just the census tracks
for San Francisco here.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So it's a really
nice data set.
And this is actually one of
the most popular use cases
I've seen is doing
census data.
Everybody always wants the state
boundaries and province
boundaries.
A lot of that data, like you
said, the official data
sources provide these
shapefiles, which makes this a
really powerful tool.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, exactly.
Cool.
PAUL SAXMAN: Maybe in a few
more weeks, we can do some
census data analysis.
MANO MARKS: Right, yeah.
Cool.
PAUL SAXMAN: Awesome.
So that's pretty much it.
So we have basic techniques,
just loading JavaScript
objects, making them editable in
the browser, in the map, so
that you can actually export
them again, kind of clean up
your data or beautify
your data.
And then we see some advanced
techniques using shapefiles to
get the shapefiles
into your map.
And then, as we mentioned
before, you can just
json.stringify, and I get that
data back out again in a
format so you don't have
to ever parse it again.
Although, I assume some of this
data might be licensed.
But that's up for the
user to investigate.
So if you guys have any
questions, post them in the
comments, please, and we'll
try to get back to you.
And Mano's data is kind
of in code review.
Mine's getting ramped
up for code review.
So I know we said this
a few weeks ago.
Before, I was on vacation.
But the code is on the way,
because we definitely want to
get it in your guys' hands
to see what you
guys can do with it.
So enjoy, and we'll
see you next week.
MANO MARKS: All right.
Thanks a lot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]